big ego I'll show you a big ego I kind
of walked right into that one didn't I
yeah the taco truck damn what a waste of
tacos
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
puts out new episodes only slightly more
often than Marvel puts out new superhero
movies I mean seriously
it feels like infinity war just happened
but it's already time to put that one
behind us to focus on a story with some
smaller stakes you might have noticed
that Scott Lang aka the ant-man was
absent from the latest Avengers movie
and that's not a case of him bein tucked
away in some microscopic hiding place
believe me I checked every promotional
poster out there they found some weird
things by doing that too like this and
this oh there's a hidden Mickey that
Illuminati symbol wasn't all that
surprising considering it's Disney but
ya know ant-man as far as the eye could
see all we hear in the movie is that he
and Hawkeye quote took a deal since
being a hero was too hard on their
families all being a superhero is hard
is it boohoo now half the universe is
dead not like that's gonna be a lot
easier on the fam anyway in case you've
forgotten ant-man has the ability to
shrink down to amp size using what's
known as Pym particles the marvelous
marvelous get it miracle matter that can
mess with the size mass and density of
any substance we most often see him
using the power of the Pym particle to
shrink himself down to the size of an
ant however one of the most memorable
ant-man seems from the MCU has to be him
doing the reverse in Captain American
Captain American the Korean ripoff
version of Captain America in Captain
America Civil War he blows himself up to
massive size becoming the most powerful
hero on the battlefield
throwing trucks around taking missiles
to the chest basically turning
unstoppable until spider-man decides to
take a page from Luke Skywalker's
playbook and ties up his legs to trip
him like an at-at that forgot how to
walk
I'm calling BS here by the way it is the
most unbelievable part of the movie
perhaps the most unbelievable part of
the MCU Peter Parker clearly would know
what all of those things are named
anyway it makes you wonder why doesn't
ant-man use this power more often do it
all the time really because this is the
first time we've ever seen you do it in
the movie what all right so at first
this might seem like a lazy cop-out by
the writers but when you look at the
real-life science it actually makes
sense being big doesn't just take a
fictional subatomic Pym particle a power
like this is gonna have some weird side
effects to Scotts body as it turns out
there's an extreme cost for being big
and that's the lesson for today
how being bigger isn't always being
better and considering it's a power is
gonna be using again in a second movie
ant-man and the wasp learning the
oddities that come with being big is
gonna be essential so that it doesn't
end every fight hangry have you ever
stopped to wonder why an elephant is
less agile than a mouse I mean sure we
all intuitively know that big things
tend to move slower but why you might
say that it's because they weigh more
and yeah that's certainly true but
consider this if you took a mouse and
blew it up
wouldn't it retain the same abilities
that allow it to scamper around or by
the same token if you take Scott Lang
and athletic superhero and do the
equivalent of dropping him into
Photoshop to stretch the corner of his
transform box Whitney just have the same
abilities but bigger and stronger than
before he's still the same proportions
after all I mean sure he may be gaining
more mass but at the same time his
muscles are also growing and gaining
strength including all of those fast
twitch muscle fibers that humans use
when they sprint - why is it so much
harder for mega Scott to perform basic
actions when he's big in these fight
scenes well believe it or not but the
answer is actually a universal law of
mathematics that applies to all matter
in the universe man between this and the
last ant-man theory about how he would
be able to create black holes ant-man
seems to be the key to unlocking the
secrets of existence maybe that's why
he's not an infinity war he's too ope
this secret universal law is known as
the square-cube law
all the way back to Galileo in 1638 yeah
the same Galileo who discovered Saturn's
rings the moons of Jupiter and taught
the world that planets orbit around the
Sun meanwhile Here I am rewatching civil
wars Airport scene covered in cheeto
dust Galileo making the rest of the
world feel like a slacker since 1640
anyway teaching people that they weren't
the center of the universe didn't make
him very popular with the Roman
Inquisition or Twitter quite frankly
resulting in him getting put under house
arrest and since he didn't have access
to candy crush or cutthroat kitchen
reruns it gave him a whole lot of time
to do math math that led to yet another
discovery that makes us all feel like
underachievers the square-cube law
aka exactly what we need to analyze and
man the easiest way to explain the law
is this imagine a tesseract that's one
inch by one inch by one inch it has a
surface area of six square inches
because each face has an area of one
square inch and there are six phases the
volume is 1 times 1 times 1 or 1 cubic
inch great if only AP calc exams were
this easy now suppose that we double
each dimension of the tesseract making
it 2 by 2 by 2 surface areas now 24
square inches and volume is now 8 cubic
inches our surface area increased by a
factor of 4 but the volume increased by
a factor of 8 now look at this we
doubled the size of the tesseract right
meaning that we multiplied everything by
2 but the surface area increased by 2
squared or 4 and the volume increased by
2 cubed or 8 if we had tripled the size
of everything from our 1 by 1 by 1
tesseract surface area would now be 54
and volume 27 surface area would have
increased by a factor of 9 or 3 squared
and volume by a factor of 27 or 3 cubed
in other words by increasing the
dimension by a given factor the surface
area will increase by the square of that
factor and the volume will increase by
the cube of that factor that is the
square cube law in a nutshell
congratulations you made it through all
the math for today's episode here's a
chocolate and an achievement and a
thousand points added to your theorists
score make sure you keep that one in a
safe place now then what's the
significance of all those darn Tesar
acts - Ant Man and his gigantism
well this ant-man grows other properties
are gonna change as well specifically
his mass is gonna increase in the same
way that his volume does it'll be the
cube of whatever factor he increases by
so if he scales up by five his mass is
multiplied by five cubed or a hundred
and twenty five times and that's cool
and all but there's a big problem here
strength only scales with area when you
want to figure out how strong a bone is
you don't look at how long it is or how
much volume it has you only care about
how thick it is you care about its
cross-sectional area the same applies to
muscle strength so at five times the
size and a hundred and twenty five times
the weight ant-man strength is only
gonna multiply by 25 the TLDR of all
this when you make something bigger
you're not actually making it stronger
by the same amount the more you scale
something up it becomes relatively less
and less straw for an example of this in
nature just look at deer white-tailed
deer are a hundred and fifty pounds
while L are six hundred pounds just by
looking at him you can tell that the
Elks legs are much thicker than the
lighter white-tailed deer legs this is
because an Elks bones and muscles need
to be much thicker to support the extra
weight but even in spite of all that
extra girth elk are still more likely to
break their bones the long story short
here is supporting additional mass is
hard it is biologically very difficult
it requires a lot of extra internal
infrastructure in your body
infrastructure that humans and ant-man
specifically just aren't built for so
let's take one more look at ant-man if
we figure out the factor of increased
for ant-man size we can quickly assess
how that would affect his mass and
strength now in the trailers for the new
movie we hear him bragging about how big
he's able to get how big did you get
twenty-one feet you 65 feet sixty-five
the actor who plays ant-man Paul Rudd is
reportedly 5 foot 10 inches meeting that
ant-man has to be able to scale up to a
maximum of 11 times his normal body size
now remember the square-cube law his
mass and volume will increase by a cube
of that factor of increase so his
resulting mass is going to increase by a
factor of 11 times 11 times 11 or 1331
Webb
I'd say that Ruud weighs in at about 171
pounds or 78 kilos so in giant form he's
actually gonna be weighing in at a
modest 220 7601 pounds or 100 3800 18
kilograms that's the same as 15
elephants or about one space shuttle
however the cross sectional area of his
muscles and bones will only increase by
the square of 11 or 121 getting over a
hundred times stronger might seem like a
lot but it means almost nothing when you
consider that he's over a thousand times
heavier than he was which explains why
Ant Man who's normally an agile
superhero capable of all kinds of
acrobatic feats is reduced to a
slow-moving behemoth in civil war
honestly considering how much additional
weight his legs are carrying it's a
wonder that he's even able to be
standing at all which begs the question
or for all of you on reddit who are
bothered by that idiomatic usage of the
phrase raises the question could he
actually stand well it took a bit of
digging but I found out bones are much
better at handling compressive forces
than shear forces this is because bones
are made up of columns of collagen and
calcium phosphate like bundles of twigs
and because they run vertically through
the bone they give the bone strength
through its leg to show you just how big
of a difference all this makes it takes
about 4,000 Newton's of force to
fracture your femur when you hit it this
way a shear direction but 50,000
Newton's of force when you apply the
force this way a compressive force over
ten times more force required that's
according to the e study guide for
physics by the way it was a hard number
to find anyway at normal human size it
would mean that Scott Lang would need to
weigh over 11,000 240 pounds to break
his legs no big worries there or for the
rest of humanity no matter how many
cheeseburgers we eat but then like Mario
jump man on his shrooms we Giganta Fayed
his leg strength scales by 121 meaning
that he can now support around 1 million
360 thousand forty pounds on his legs
and considering he weighs in at just
under 230 pounds when he's in large
scale he is well in the clear someone
get that man an orange slice he deserves
it but what's coolest about all of this
is that well yes it explains why he has
to be slow in
careful in his mega form he also
explains how he's so incredibly powerful
in his micro form because you see all of
this also works in Reverse if increasing
your size increases the ratio of mass to
strength then decreasing your muscle
mass should have the opposite effect
more strength relative to your size
according to the Marvel website ant-man
can shrink himself down to half an inch
that's him scaling himself down a
hundred and forty two times which means
that his bone and muscle cross section
will be shrunk down by a hundred and
forty two squared but his volume and
mass will be shrunk down by a hundred
and forty two cubed
that means that when ant-man is half an
inch tall his strength ratio increases
by a factor of a hundred and forty two
that's the equivalent of a six-foot man
feeling like they only weigh 1.4 pounds
imagine what kind of athletic beats your
body would be capable of if you gained
that factor of strength you could lift
things that were way bigger than you in
fact that's exactly what we observe in
the animal kingdom ants are capable of
lifting objects that are hundreds of
times their own weight while elephants
are only capable of lifting objects that
are around one tenth of their weight
true in absolute terms the elephant
might be capable of lifting bigger
objects but proportionally the amp seems
so much stronger and that's a big part
of where ant Man's powers come from for
example he has the ability to change
size at will while maintaining his
momentum meeting he starts an incredible
sprint while small and blows himself up
to deliver a devastating punch I always
hear the phrase that bigger is better
but as we saw in civil war being big has
its costs while ant man's gigantic form
might be one of the most visually
impressive things we see him do in the
movies his real strength lies not in his
ability to grow but his ability to
shrink Scott Lang proves that it's not
the size of your superhero but rather
the size of their power ratio if you to
our flesh comparing sizes 65 well the
science proves it at least Scott still
seems really proud of that 65 footer but
hey that's just a theory Oh
film theory and if you missed my last
ant-man theory on why is technically the
most devastating character in the Marvel
MCU it's right here click the button
tear left Oh
make sure you give that subscribe button
a big old smack so you can be updated
about what crazy theories we have coming
up next like have you ever wondered what
the optimum strategy is for winning the
purge oh yeah there's a right answer for
solving the purge one that you're gonna
find out next week but only if you hit
the subscribe button hurry
you only have 5 seconds left in this
video to do it 5 4 3 don't get left in
the purge